Welcome to Roman architecture.
I'm professor Kleiner.
And what I'd like to do today is to,
uh,
give you a sense of some of the great buildings and some of the themes that we
will be studying together this semester.
I think it's important to note from the outset that Roman architecture is
primarily an architecture of cities.
The Romans structured a manmade worldwide empire out of architectural forms,
and those architectural forms revolutionize the ancient world and exerted a
lasting influence on the architecture and the architects of post-classical
times.
This semester we will be considered concerned primarily with urban communities,
with urban communities,
and we will in the first half of the semester,
we will focus on the city of Rome and in the second and,
and also central Italy,
including Pompei.
Uh,
and I wanted to show you at the outset and aerial view of Rome.
You see it over here on the left hand side of the screen,
uh,
that situates us in the very core of the ancient city.
You see the famous coliseum,
the very icon of Rome at the upper right.
You see the Roman forum as it looks today.
Uh,
and you see a,
a part of the capital line hill,
uh,
transformed by Michelangelo into the famous Compa Doleo as well as the
[inaudible] in periodically and with Salini built by Mussolini and the imperial
fora.
So the city of Rome,
again,
we'll be concentrating on at the beginning of the semester as well as the city
of palm pay,
an aerial view of Pompei.
As it looks today,
you can see many of the buildings of the city,
uh,
including the houses and the shops.
Uh,
and also the entertainment district.
This is the theater and the Music Hall of Ancient Tom Pay.
The amphitheater is over here and you can see of course looming in the
background,
uh,
the Mount Vesuvius,
the mountain that caused all that trouble in 79 a d.
So that's the first half of the semester.
The second half of the semester,
uh,
we are going to be going out into the provinces and to the Roman provinces and
that is going to take us and we're going to look at the province is both in the
eastern and the western part of the empire.
And that will take us to Roman Greece.
Uh,
it will take us to Asia Minor,
uh,
Asia Minor,
which of course is modern Turkey.
It will take us to North Africa.
It will take us to the Middle East,
uh,
in what's now Jordan and Syria.
Uh,
and it will also take us to Europe,
to Western Europe,
uh,
two cities,
two cities in France and to cities in Spain.
Uh,
and let me just show you an example of some of the buildings that we'll look at
is we traveled to the provinces.
This is the library of Kelsey's in emphasis on the western coast of Turkey.
Uh,
this,
the theater a spectacularly well preserved theater at sub brotha.
Ah,
you see in the upper right hand side and down here a restored view of the
masterful of palace of Diocletian when they're the late Roman emperors in a
place called Split,
which is in Croatia along the fabulously gorgeous Dalmatian coast today.
So those are just a sampling of the kinds of buildings that will look at in the
provinces.
We're going to be,
uh,
seeing,
we'll be concentrating on the ways in which the Romans planned and built their
cities.
Uh,
and it's important to note from the very outset that Rome itself grew in a very
ad hoc way.
Uh,
and we can tell that here's a Google earth image,
uh,
showing,
that core of Rome with the Colosseum,
uh,
with the famous Vic Modern Victor Emmanuel monument that looks either like a
wedding cake or a typewriter.
It's very white and it's called the wedding cake by a lot of the locals.
You see that here,
but it's a landmark in Rome.
Uh,
and uh,
the capital inhale comp Idalia over here,
the forum,
the Roman Forum of the imperial fora on this side,
but you can see from the relatively crooked,
uh,
and narrow streets of the city of Rome as they look from above today.
Uh,
you can see that again,
the city grew in a fairly ad hoc way.
As I mentioned,
it wasn't planned all at once.
It just grew up over time,
beginning in the eighth century BC.
Now,
this is interesting because what we know about the Romans is when they were left
to their own devices,
uh,
and they could build a city from scratch,
they didn't let it grow in an ad hoc way.
They,
they structured it in a,
in a very,
very methodical way that was basically based on military strategy,
military planning,
the Romans,
they couldn't have conquered the world without obviously having a masterful,
uh,
military enterprise.
Uh,
and they,
uh,
everywhere they went on their various campaigns,
there's various military campaigns they would build,
uh,
build camps.
And those camps were always laid out in a very geometric plan along the grid,
uh,
usually square or rectangular.
So when we begin to see the Romans building their ideal Roman city,
they turn to that so called costume or military camp design,
and they build their cities that way.
And I show you here one example.
We're using Google earthier again,
another example of an example of a city,
a called Tim Gad,
t I,
m,
g,
a,
D,
which is in modern Algeria.
Uh,
and the ancient city is still survives a,
and if we look at this Google earth image of it,
you can see there's no later accretions as we have in Rome.
No later civilizations on top of it.
You can see the ideal Roman plan,
which is I said is usually either a square or a rectangle.
It has in the center of the two main streets of the city.
The North South Street is called the Cardo,
ca RDO.
Uh,
the East West street is called the Dec Humanitas,
d.
C u.
We'll go back to all of this in the future so you don't have to worry about it
today.
Uh,
the carto and the deck [inaudible] and you can see that they cross exactly.
They intersect exactly at the center of the city.
Uh,
and then the rest of the city is arranged in blocks,
very regular blocks.
This grid plan that I mentioned before.
And then some of the major monuments,
whether it's the theater or the forum,
you know,
are arranged in different parts of the city.
Uh,
and then these blocks constitute essentially the housing and the shops and so on
and so forth.
This is a city that was planned and around 100 and under the emperor Trajan.
Uh,
and again,
it gives us an inkling of what the Romans,
when the Romans thought about ideal Roman town planning,
it was this grid plan,
not wrong,
but this grid plan that they had very much in mind.
Cities like Rome,
like Tim Gad,
uh,
and most of the others that we'll look at in the course of the semester.
We're surrounded by defensive walls as a mass,
as a major military machine in its own right.
Rome was only too aware of the dangers of,
of attack from others.
And consequently they walled their cities.
And we will look at the two major walls in Rome as well as walls and other parts
of the Roman world.
I promise not to spend too much time on walls,
uh,
because they're essentially piles of stone,
but,
but they're,
they're important in their own right.
And I will speak to them on occasion,
and especially the two in Rome,
you see them here.
This is the first row wall in Rome,
the so called Serbian walls,
which was built in the republic and the Roman Republic to,
to surround the city,
the Republican city,
and essentially the seven hills,
the famous seven hills of Rome to surround the seven hills of Rome.
Uh,
in the fourth century BC.
You see a section of it here,
uh,
this wall,
any of you who've come to Rome by train and the stops Yonei tear mini,
uh,
see a very extensive section of the Serbian walls as you get I,
and if you've noticed it,
but you should see an extensive section of the survey and walls right outside
the train station.
This is a different section than I,
a picture I took on the Aventine Hill,
uh,
showing a part of that wall.
And that was eventually replaced by later walls.
A city grew over time.
It needed a more extensive,
broader,
a wall system.
Uh,
and in the late third century Aidy under the emperor really religion,
the famous or really and walls were built,
uh,
the really in walls.
As you know,
I,
there's no way you've missed those.
I'm sure if you've been in Rome,
you've seen the really end walls.
They're are,
they're very much,
they're,
uh,
at least if you've left the city,
maybe if you've just gone into the core of the city and having gone beyond that,
you might not have seen them.
But if you've left the city,
you've seen the are really in walls,
a very impressive,
uh,
set of walls that and circled the later city.
One thing that's apparent to you as you look at these,
even if you didn't have no knowledge whatsoever,
Roman architecture is these are made a very different kinds of materials.
So technical issues come to the fore right away is one analyzes this sort of
thing in the early period,
essentially blocks of stone piled one on top of the other for the wall here,
or a more sophisticated use later on in the empire of a new technology that
we're going to talk about a lot this semester.
And that is concrete.
And what concrete did to revolutionize Roman architecture concrete in this
particular case?
Uh,
faced with brick,
we talked about regular town planning,
uh,
and,
the location of the carto and the deck.
You Montas I want to show you just an example of this.
This is the city in Italy,
uh,
in this case,
the city of palm pay.
You see it here in plan.
This is a plan of Pompei as it looked just at the moment that Vesuvius erupted.
So in August of 79,
a d this was the way palm pay was at that particular time.
Uh,
you can see it's not really a rectangle.
It's a kind of Elongate it sort of an oval,
kind of an oval and irregular oval.
Uh,
but it has the sense,
you know,
I think it has the center,
it shows you that again,
even for,
um,
for evil,
even though the Romans were thinking in with,
to,
to try to create their cities in a very regular way.
You know,
it didn't always work out exactly that way,
depending on the terrain and so on and so forth.
But this is a rough,
it's sort of an irregular,
a rectangle,
as you can see here.
But if you look very carefully,
you sort of say to yourself like,
where's the Cardo?
Where's the decades?
Just told us the card on the deck Montas Intersect in the center.
Like where are they?
Why aren't they intersecting the center?
Well,
surprise,
maybe not such a surprise.
If you look over here at the bottom left,
you will actually see the original city upon pay in the fourth century BC,
the third century BC,
the second century BC.
Pompei didn't look like this.
Pump pay looked like,
like this.
Uh,
and if you look very carefully at just this section where we have the buildings
and the various colors,
you will see that there is indeed a carto and a deck.
You Montas that intersect exactly at the,
uh,
at the center of this roughly square.
So this was actually pretty regular originally.
This roughly square city of pay at three.
We find the forum because the forum is always at the intersection.
The Romans try,
they're very careful about this sort of thing.
Tried to put uh,
their,
um,
their forum right at the intersection of the carto and the deck [inaudible].
You see that here.
Uh,
and then you see a lot of other buildings splayed off to either side,
the law court or the basilica.
Another tip,
a temple here,
here,
the main temple of Jupiter Senate House or Korea and a series of other religious
and uh,
comparable structures on the right hand side.
So it began as a quite regular plan.
Hardo indeck,
you Montas intersecting at the SEC,
at the center,
a forum,
uh,
right at the intersection of those two.
And then over time it grew,
it grew and expanded and the streets the same street,
the car to,
you know,
expand it.
Although it was no longer exactly at the center of the city.
This is a view from Google earth that shows you just pretty much,
I tried to angle it in such a way that it looks that it's exactly the same
angle,
a close to exactly the same angle as the plan that we just looked at before.
And you can see over here the amphitheater,
uh,
you can see,
um,
uh,
many of the streets including the,
the shops and the houses.
And you can see over here the forum as it looks today,
uh,
from the air.
And again,
it shows you how helpful Google and of course,
as you know,
using Google Earth yourselves,
uh,
for other purposes,
you know that you can go way down and you can find the entire city and then you
can go and explore,
uh,
each individual building,
on your own and in your own time.
In fact,
that's what I've done here.
Here you see a closer view of the forum in palm pay as it looks today,
uh,
from the air via Google earth here at the left.
And I compare it to this plan that comes from your textbook,
one of your two textbooks that the book by J B Ward Perkins,
uh,
Wi,
which is the of the two,
the more,
well,
they're both important,
but then they both do different things.
But one of the two important books that we'll be using this semester,
uh,
here is the plan from that book.
And you can see the way in which this forum and this forum is very important at
Pompei because it's very early in date.
And consequently we will talk about it a fair amount.
We see this the way Roman forums were usually arranged was to have one general
open rectangular space open to the sky,
surrounded by columns.
Uh,
with a temple.
The key,
the most important temple,
the chief temple,
uh,
pushed up against one of the short back walls and dominating the space in front
of it.
This is a capital e and we'll talk about what a capital Liam is in a future
lecture,
but it is a temple to Jupiter and others.
As we shall see,
temple of Apollo over here,
the basilica or law courts over here.
Uh,
and you can see interestingly enough,
they have essentially the same shape as the central forum proper.
Uh,
a brick tank rectangular with a colonnade in the center.
And then something on one side.
It's not another temple,
but rather a tribunal,
uh,
a place from which the judge would try the cases in the law courts.
We see the Senate House over here and a series of other buildings including a
market place and some other buildings here on the right hand side.
Uh,
so a typical Roman forum at its earliest stage,
very early on,
second century BC,
and is therefore an extremely important building for us just so that you get a
sense of what some of these look like.
In actuality,
this is the basilica or the Law Court of the forum of pump or as part of it,
which is part of the forum of palm pay.
And we see that tribunal that I mentioned before to story tribunal from which
the judge would try the cases.
The building isn't as well preserved as we'd like,
although there's quite a bit there.
And what is their,
allows us to,
uh,
to create this kind of reconstruction drawing where we can get a very good sense
of what this building actually looked like in antiquity.
You see the tribunal over there,
uh,
you see that there are a double stories with columns on either side.
I,
you see these colossal columns along the aisle,
but most importantly,
unlike the forum which was open to the sky,
this is roofed and it had a flat roof with what's called a coffered ceiling.
We'll talk about that later in the term.
But then a sloping roof from the outside and Basilic,
those were always roofed.
And that's what distinguishes them from a lot of other Roman buildings.
Roman temple architecture,
the temple of the temples of Jupiter and Apollo at palm pay,
or not that WellPreserved,
but some Roman temples are magnificently preserved.
I mean,
look at this one.
It's pristine.
It's like it was,
was created yesterday as a,
as a,
as a duplicate of what a Roman temple,
uh,
or a restoration of what Roman temple might've looked like.
You could,
you could put this in Memphis or somewhere like that and think that you had a
nice replica of a Roman temple.
That's how well preserved it is.
It's an amazing temple.
It's just happens to be WellPreserved in part because it was reused over time.
Most recently as a small archeological museum,
this is the famous Meson cafe or a square house for obvious reasons,
uh,
that is in the beautiful French town of Neem,
south of France.
Uh,
and you see it here in all its glory.
And think as you look about this,
look at this.
How many banks were based on this planet?
I mean you can go to almost any small city in America and see a bank that looks
something like this,
which just gives you some sense of,
again,
how influential Roman architecture has been over time.
It's a quite traditional temple.
We'll talk about the difference between traditional temple architecture and more
innovative temple architecture in the course of the semester.
And as innovative as it gets is what is one of the key buildings of Roman
architecture,
which is of course the famous Pantheon in Rome.
I'm sure there's none of you who's been in Rome who hasn't been inside the
Pantheon.
It is an incredible building.
This is a Google map.
It was done during the,
um,
the building was put up during the reign of the very important from the
architectural standpoint and many other but very important emperor Hadrian.
Uh,
and we see,
this is again,
one of the,
um,
one of the wonderful things about Google earth because you're seeing here the
modern city.
Uh,
but you're also seeing in three d,
uh,
the,
the building still stands and it's an incredible condition,
but you're also seeing the building almost as it would have been in ancient
times,
surrounded by its modern environment.
It's a temple is a very distinctive and innovative temple because when you look
at it from the front,
you see it as a kind of traditional porch that is not unlike the one in the
Meson Keray with columns that support a pediment looks like earlier Greek or
trust and architecture.
Uh,
but what's very innovative about it is that once you go into the building,
you see that this is not about this,
this is all about an interior space and extraordinary interior space that is
shaped by light,
that is shaped by a genius essentially.
And this,
this image is actually one of those that gives you a sense of,
of,
of the kind of thing that I've been able to incorporate into this course that I
didn't always use before,
which includes,
uh,
many,
many of my own images.
And this one I'm particularly proud of.
It's a very atmospheric view of the,
uh,
of the Dome of the Pantheon and I think really gives you almost more than
anything else cause you a sense almost more than anything else that I can show
you today of,
of Roman.
It's best of the power and glory of Rome and the Roman architecture.
I'm very biased,
but as far as I'm concerned,
this is the greatest building ever conceived.
Bye by man.
So there you are.
We'll see by the end of the semester whether you agree with me or you think I'm
absolutely wrong about that.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
another extraordinary structure and one that enables me to say something that
you'll hear me say more than once.
And I know I'm biased,
but say more than once in the course of the semester,
is that,
is that there isn't much that the Romans didn't discover,
didn't create a and not just in architecture and all kinds of ways.
Uh,
and this is a good example of that.
This is the so called the famous markets of Trajan in Rome,
part of the great forum of the Emperor Trajan in Rome.
And you can see that what the Romans have done is taken a hill,
one of the famous seven hills,
the queer,
and it'll hell taking that hill,
cut it back,
poured concrete on it,
and created this incredible shopping center on the side of the hill.
If this isn't the beginning of mall architecture,
I don't know what it is.
Shopping Mall architecture,
it's right here already.
You can shop there over 150 shops.
You can shop on a variety of levels.
You can shop in the heavy cycle.
You can shop along the via Bieber,
Radhika.
Uh,
you can shop,
you know,
shop til you drop a in this,
in this,
in this incredible mall.
Uh,
and as one looks at it in detail,
wasn't,
sees amazing things.
Uh,
this is a view of one of the shopping streets.
You can see the typical masonry that is so characteristic of Roman street design
here along.
It's,
some of the individual shops need to think that a way at the top.
That was added later.
Uh,
but you see some of the individual shops here and look how,
how ingenious the Romans have been to provide not only a ramp,
but also a series of upstairs,
flat area,
stairs and so on.
And this has all been very,
very carefully orchestrated by the designers in a way that is not only
utilitarian but also very attractive.
And then there's this,
this is the Great Hall of the,
uh,
of the markets of Trajan in Rome.
A kind of bizarre,
which also has a series of shops and also attic windows as you can see above a,
but then the goal,
the,
the particular marvel of this space is,
look what they've done above.
They have taken,
they are using concrete once again,
and this gives you some sense of the miracle of Roman concrete using concrete.
They have created a new kind of bolt,
which we call the groin vault,
uh,
which is,
which is a rib default.
And you can see the ribs very clearly here.
And they have lifted that ribbed bald on top of peers that are,
that have been attenuated and narrowed to the point,
to a very,
in a very sophisticated way,
much more than was true up to this moment.
So that they have been able to lift those groin bolts in a way that always
reminds me.
It's as if you went and opened a series of umbrellas over a space,
you know,
lifted the space up and a truly miraculous way.
And as an example,
again of the fact that the Romans is nothing,
the Romans didn't do,
it,
didn't invent a,
here you see the well known marketplace in San Francisco,
uh,
where you see essentially the same idea,
a series of shops down below,
and then this,
this magnificently lifted a ceiling above.
So Roman architecture,
as I said in the very beginning,
really had a huge impact on later architecture.
The Bat,
the markets of Trajan.
We're part of the forum complex,
the forum of Trajan,
which you see a part of here.
Uh,
the forum itself was really quite conventional.
This is an interesting building because we have a fairly can rent traditional,
uh,
approach to the forum itself and then an innovative approach to the markets.
This is a restored view of the basilica or law court of the forum of Trajan.
Uh,
you see that it's very traditional with columns and marble,
uh,
and as flat ceiling with coffers.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that's what most of the,
temp most of the forum looks like.
The market's are done in a very different style as we saw.
And this particular forum,
uh,
was not only a meeting in a marketplace or a place where,
cases could be tried,
uh,
but was also a,
a monument in stone to the military.
Victories of Trajan.
Trajan was the emperor who extended the borders of the Empire to their furthest
reaches.
And,
uh,
the monument is a,
is a testament to what is accomplished is w accomplishments were militarily and
the famous column of Trajan,
which still stands and is in magnificent condition as you can see here,
uh,
is a monument that is wrapped with a spiral freeze that,
that purports to describe,
uh,
from bottom to top all of the exploits,
all of the military exploits of Trajan is to military campaigns in Dacia.
It also served as the emperor's tomb.
It was a burial chamber down below a four urns of Trajan and his wife Platina.
Uh,
so it served not only as a,
as a commemoration of his military victory over Dacia,
which by the ways modern Romania today,
uh,
but also to victory over death for the emperor.
Every Roman city has had his bath buildings.
Most of the houses did not have running water.
So bats were extremely important,
obviously.
So most cities had more than one.
In fact,
most cities Pompei for example,
seems to have had about three a bath buildings.
They're very important both in terms of their social,
their need,
their practical needs,
and also as a place for social interaction.
Uh,
but also because there are some very interesting architectural experiments that
took place in them.
I'm going to show you in the course of the semester,
the development from the simplest bath buildings such as the ones in palm pay to
the most elaborate,
those of you who visited the baths of Caracalla in Rome,
that's an example of one of the huge and most elaborate a bath buildings.
I show you here on the left hand side of the screen.
Just as an example,
a view of,
uh,
one of the rooms of the forum bouts and Pompei the caldarium or warm room.
All of these bands had multiple spaces within them.
One of the distinctions of the earlier baths,
uh,
was that,
um,
that the men sections and the women's sections,
we're separate from one another,
and I hate to say it,
but the men had all the great rooms.
Uh,
they were bigger and they were more ornately decorated as this one is the warm
room of the men's baths,
uh,
at pom pay.
But you can see here even in much smaller scale than a building like the
Pantheon and much earlier than the Pantheon,
uh,
they're beginning to explore the curvatures of the wall,
the,
um,
send me down there.
And the way in which you can create light effects by putting holes are what are
what's called an oculus around whole,
uh,
in the,
in part of the ceiling,
uh,
and other,
rectangular holes in the ceiling to create fantastic light effects.
So they're already exploring that here in palm pay.
When we look at some of the larger bathing establishments,
the baths of Caracalla still look while they're there,
a Hoka,
they're essentially a pile huff concrete based with brick today is any of you
who've seen it?
No,
but the scale is truly colossal and one is very impressed when one wanders
around the baths of Caracalla.
But some of the others,
for example,
the baths of Diocletian have been reused in modern times.
And it's one of the reasons it's so many Roman buildings survive is because of
this kind of reuse over the centuries.
Uh,
this,
the baths of Diocletian,
part of which was transformed into a church at first by a decorated at one point
in part by Michelangelo.
And what we're looking at here,
the Church of Santa Maria,
daily on jellies,
Saint Mary of the angels.
And what we're looking at here is a view into what was the cold room where the
frig Doriam of the baths of Diocletian,
uh,
but transformed into a church,
used as the nave of the Church of Saint Mary,
of the angels.
But if you look very closely,
you'll see those same cross or groin vaults,
uh,
that we saw in the markets of Trajan,
that are also used here to lift the ceiling and a very effective way.
And then all these multicolored columns that you see are actually the columns
from the ancient building.
So even in this interior of Santa Maria de Leon,
Jillian,
we can get a sense of how ornate,
uh,
some of the decorations of some of these bath buildings work.
We're going to look at Roman theaters,
uh,
this semester.
Uh,
this is an example of one the spectacular Roman theater at all wrong in the
south of France.
You see it here.
I'm not going to go into the parts of a,
of a,
of a theater or its relationship to earlier Greek theatrical architecture.
But you can see the stair,
you can see the seats.
Uh,
you can see the orchestra,
you can see the stage buildings,
stage building that initially was decorated with a forest of columns,
only a couple of which your vibe as well as a lot of sculptural decoration.
Again,
most of which does not survive.
But one of the,
one of the points I want to make today is that the Greeks tended to build,
the Greeks always built their theaters on hillsides.
They use the natural hill to support the seats.
And that's true at all wrong as well.
But the Romans were not content to build their,
to build their,
um,
their theaters only on hillsides.
They wanted to build their theaters where they wanted to build their theaters.
And if they wanted to build a theater in downtown Rome,
they wanted to build a theater in downtown Rome.
So what they did was that they used concrete again,
uh,
to build a hill to build a hill upon which they could support those same seats.
And that's again,
an innovation that we'll talk about.
Uh,
this is the theater of Marcellus and Rome,
the earliest surviving stone theater in Rome in the eight that dates to the age
of Augustus.
But I show it to you again just to show you the wonders of Google Earth.
I've looked at this building a zillion times.
I've wandered around it.
Uh,
it is,
most of the ancient part is over on this side and I'll show that to you in
another lecture.
Uh,
but over time,
this is one of those buildings that was transformed into all sorts of things,
most recently into a fabulous condominium.
Uh,
but as you wander around it today,
you can't,
you get a sense of some of the high rise apartments that have been added to the
original theater,
but you can't get a full sense of it unless you go up above it.
And so here's where,
again,
Google earth is so helpful because we can look down on the entire complex,
see the garden seed,
some of the apartments,
see the circular driveway and so on and so forth,
which gives us information that it would be Haas possible to glean anywhere
else.
And here is,
if you let that,
that,
that transformation from modern Rome to ancient Rome take place on Google Earth,
this is what you're going to get for that same theater of Marcellus.
We just saw it and it's what it looks like today.
And Google Earth.
Here's what it looks like when you let it transform completely,
uh,
into the theater of Marcellus from ancient times.
The Coliseum,
the very icon of Rome,
Roman.
No,
no.
Roman city was without it's amphitheater.
It's place for gladiatorial,
an animal combat.
Uh,
and Rome was no exception.
The most famous,
uh,
surviving Roman amphitheater is the coliseum.
I show it to you here from the inside rather than the outside initially because
I can,
it allows me to illustrate the places where the animals were kept down below.
Uh,
but also to show you that that building has been used as a quarry.
It was used by the pope's in the princess of later Italy as a,
as a stone quarry.
They would take essentially stripped it of all its interior marble to use that
in a variety of buildings of Rome in Rome and up.
Some of those we know their identification even today.
Here's a view of one of the Carter's where you can see once again,
those are those groin vaults or ribbed vaults,
uh,
that the Romans popularized connecting all these cities with one another where
the streets of the city will look at streets,
especially in palm pay,
where they are extremely well preserved.
And these streets look very modern.
You see the polygonal stones,
but very modern and the use of the sidewalks,
the sidewalks there drains as well along the sidewalks.
And then you can see these very deep red marks where the,
uh,
where the wheels of the carts used to use it.
They,
they,
over time,
obviously they made these ruts in the pavement.
And then over here,
a small fountain,
a fountain.
I'm blessed by Hermes or mercury.
You can see him there with his wings and his caduceus,
uh,
a small,
small fountain important obviously again,
because most of the houses did not have running water and there had to be a
place that you could go to collect water for household use.
Uh,
one of the great things about palm pay of course is it gives us a sense of,
um,
of what life was like in ancient Roman times.
Daily life was like,
and we'll look at millstones or bake and,
and for bay that are part of bakeries as well as ovens that look and the Romans
invented everything look very much like a modern pizza oven.
You go over to bar,
you'll see you have one of those.
Uh,
over here when I'm shops,
we've lots of wine shops in these Roman cities and they're particularly
WellPreserved and Herculaneum and,
and in Pompei,
uh,
with these clay amphorae that we're used to hold wines that were brought to
Italy and also sometimes oils that were brought to Italy from different parts of
the world.
Uh,
every Roman city had it's Mcdonald's or it's Wendy's sorts burger king.
and I show one of those to you here.
It's called a Thermop oleum.
As you can see down below Thermop oleum a Thermop oleum was essentially,
I mean,
what it was made up of is a,
um,
uh,
is a series of a counter,
a counter with a series of recesses and each day,
uh,
those who,
those who ran this,
they're Napoleon put different food in there.
And so when you got hungry again,
the whole sort of fast food idea,
you're just walked,
walked by,
like in the cafeteria,
point out what you wanted,
they'd serve it to you and you'd be on your way.
So very much a fast food.
So we see lots of them in Pompeii and Herculaneum.
We'll look at Roman houses.
This is one example.
The house of the Betty in Pompei spectacularly preserved house,
uh,
where we can see a pool that was actually used for collecting water hole in the
ceiling,
but a view from the atrium of the house into the garden,
the garden over here,
you get a sense of it,
the greenery,
the Marble furniture,
the fountains,
and then the paintings on the walls.
I mentioned at the beginning we'll spend a fair amount of time,
we'll spend a few lectures on Roman painting.
And the reason that I do that is,
is big.
It's absolutely gorgeous and it's fascinating,
uh,
but it also allows us to get a better understanding of interior decoration among
the Romans,
how they decorated their walls.
But also because as you can see from this one example from Boscoreale and now in
the Metropolitan Museum,
the famous met Qubica alum,
uh,
which is decorated with second style Roman wall painting,
that these paintings often depict buildings.
They,
they are architectural paintings and they are very important in that regard
because we see,
we often see,
uh,
experimentation in painting before we see it in architecture there.
So they're going to be some things,
for example,
this broken triangular pediment that we're going to see first and painting.
And then in build architecture.
So painting extremely important for us.
We'll also go to the city of Ostia,
the port of Rome,
which is a city very different from a Pompei because it is essentially a second
century Roman city rather than a first century Roman city.
Uh,
the,
the construction technique is a concrete faced with brick.
I show you one example of that,
but what's most interesting about the houses and in Ostia has to do with the
kind of city it was,
again,
the port of Rome,
a commercial city.
Uh,
it was very congested.
People were not as wealthy as those in the resort town of palm pay.
Uh,
and consequently they,
people didn't have single story houses like the one in palm pay that I just
showed me before,
but rather apartment houses with multistory stories,
a kind of condominium idea.
Uh,
and these are fascinating in their difference from those in palm pay.
And that's a difference that we will surely explore the very well to do lived in
very well to do had villas.
The emperors had villas all along what is now the Amalfi Coast coppery the
Ireland of coppery.
The Emperor Augustus in Siberia is had 12 villas on the island of Coppery,
the most extraordinary villa Hadrian's villa at Tivoli,
which I show you here from the air.
Uh,
a kind of microcosm of the empire at that particular time with extraordinary
buildings,
with pools,
uh,
decorated with sculpture that show the eclectic taste of the emperor who liked
things Roman like things Greek,
like things that Gypson,
uh,
and uh,
it statues of he,
he was married,
but he also had a beloved young boy,
uh,
whom he met him Athenia and tenuous.
The famous antenna was,
uh,
that he met in Mathenia and who became the love of his life.
And when antenna was died,
he,
he created all kinds of shrines where antinatalism is very important
architecturally because of all these infesting shrines.
But in each of those shrines he created statues of antenna was,
and this is one showing ingenuous as an Egyptian Pharaoh,
which was perfect for this particular locale,
uh,
because it was meant to conjure up a canal in Egypt.
We're going to look at to market texture.
I want to show you this very quickly,
but we're going to look at a lot of to market texture because to market texture
is particularly interesting because the only practical consideration for a tomb,
it had to house the remains of the deceased.
That's it.
So you could,
you could be very whimsical and personal,
personal about the kind of tomb you want it to be buried.
And this is a series at palm pay,
uh,
but we're going to look at those of the emperor Augustus who was buried in a
mausoleum that went back to those of the earlier trust skins.
Kings who ruled ruled Rome before.
Uh,
the emperors did a and he built a round tube with an earthen mound,
very similar to that of the Atrust skins.
Hadrian.
The famous emperor Hadrian was also buried and around tomb in the well known
causal San Angelo and Rome.
Today with its beautiful Bernini Bridge at the angels,
the Bernini's angels on the bridge,
also around tomb in its current form transformed into a fortress.
It was used by the pope's when they need to,
to hide out during times of trouble,
very whimsical tombs,
including,
uh,
this pyramid of,
a man by the name of Cassius.
Uh,
and he built this tomb during a time of,
um,
when a wave of things Egyptian came into Rome at the time that,
Cleopatra Augustus defeated Cleopatra and Antony.
And then even these communal tombs,
communal burial places for the less to do a where their remains were pret placed
in earns.
We'll also look at tombs and other parts of the Roman world.
This is a famous tomb,
a rock cut tomb,
and Peatra in what is now a Jordan,
uh,
where,
and you can see that the,
um,
that the tomb is essentially the rock.
In fact,
the burial chamber is inside the Rock and the facade has been carved out of the
rock.
We're going to talk about,
uh,
about aqueducts in the course of the semester.
Just fleetingly show you to a way the ways in which the Romans brought for those
they conquered,
they provided amenities including water that was brought from a great distance.
This is the famous poem to gardening and this the one I showed you before on
Google Earth,
the fabulous,
uh,
aqueduct at Segovia that marches its way through the city.
I have just a couple of minutes and I basically wanted to close just making two
very quick points about the difference between traditional Roman architecture
and innovative Roman architecture.
I'm not going to go into that in any detail here.
It's going to be the topic of one of our lectures very soon.
But this transformation from temples that are based on Greek and a trust can
prototypes like that one here to something like the Pantheon.
I also want to mention from the start that unlike other courses and architecture
where you may have been studying Frank Lloyd Wright or Barmini Francesco
Borromini or Frank Gehry,
uh,
we have very few names of architects preserved from Roman Times.
Uh,
because it was a patron who was all not the architect.
And I'll explain that in a future lecture.
Uh,
but we have sub and we'll talk about them when we do.
we will also see,
and I've just want to end up where I began,
which is to say again,
that Roman architecture had a huge impact on architecture of post-classical
times.
The Roman basilica became the Christian Church.
The round tomb of Rome became the round church,
uh,
in the early medieval in Byzantine periods.
Uh,
tombs like the one in Jordan that I showed you just before,
which form what I call a kind of baroque phase of Roman architecture where the
models for a 17th century baroque architecture in Rome,
for example,
Borromini Son Carlino,
uh,
the Pantheon,
had you all know what this is,
Uva,
the Pantheon had a huge impact.
There are many pantheons everywhere,
including in this country,
banks and the like.
Thomas Jefferson looked to the Pantheon to design his Rotunda at the University
of Virginia and the lawn that lay beyond,
uh,
but from,
for us in this classroom at this particular time,
the most important impact as far as I'm concerned of Roman architecture on more
modern architecture,
uh,
has to do with the amphitheater at Pompei which you see here,
my favorite amphitheater,
the Rome,
the coliseum is more famous.
The,
the amphitheater at palm pay is earlier in date.
And what's significant for us in this classroom at this particular time is the
amphitheater at palm pay.
And I kid you not is the model for our own amphitheater and that is the Yale
bowl and it is the model.
This is the building and you see it here from the air,
the amphitheater in Pompei on which the Yale Bowl,
uh,
was based.
So again,
the Romans have clearly had a huge impact on architecture worldwide,
on our own architecture.
And we think we live on a gothic campus.
But I'll show you in the course of the semester how much Roman,
how many Roman buildings there are.
In fact,
we had a post,
and just to get you inspired,
we had a post in an earlier year in which,
uh,
people,
when people went around the campus to take pictures and then post them online of
buildings that they thought were influenced by those of the Roman passing.
At any rate,
that's it for today.
Great to see you meet you all.
If any of you have any questions at all,
I'm happy to answer them.
As are the teaching fellows.